hello i'm anthony russo i'm joe russo
and this is the wired autocomplete
interview
i would say that our number one note is
do it again faster action
okay
board number one here what are the russo
brothers
known for
they're devastating good looks remember
online back in the days
there's the plumbers in new jersey the
russo brothers and then there's a pair
of like i think italian singers they
were the original what are the russo
brothers favorite movies anything by
sergio leone
um anything by truffaut
uh anything by coppola scorsese scorsese
kubrick the bowery boys david lean any
uh abba costello film it's almost
embarrassing to name our favorite movies
because i feel like
they're all the great movies they are
what what if the russo brothers directed
justice league i think people conflate
dc and marvel what if or to play off the
marvel series what is it i i don't know
how to answer that see the snyder cut
that's the definitive cut yeah i don't
need to see anything else what did the
russo brothers
do on community what didn't we do on
community we exactly produced that show
we directed
a lot of the episodes cast that pilot
costumed it designed it shot it we
missed community we missed our community
family yeah everybody but chevy chase we
missed
yeah not really
what
question what
happened to them
i don't know what didn't happen it's
like a year and a half after end game
and they're like what happened to those
guys it might be that band in milwaukee
that they're referring remember when
they were he hit their peak with end
game and then they just fell off the map
all right
how were the russo brothers discovered
but we were at a film festival called
slam dance in 1997.
that's bc i made a film called pieces
that was a very non-linear experimental
movie that only soda berg would love
uh and he did and he helped us get our
next filmmaker welcome to collingwood
and here we are how many films have the
rooster brothers directed we know the
answer to this right a lot thunder 10.
but there's a lot of tv shows in there
there's a lot of commercials how do the
russo brothers direct actors very
carefully mm-hmm you have to we like to
keep the actors from thinking too much
so we do give very concise
directorial notes most of our work is
done in prep with them so when they get
to set they're ready to go we love
actors and we spend a lot of time
speaking with them
prior to shooting to sort of develop
common understanding of the character
common understanding the film what we're
going for then when we get to set we
like to move fairly quickly one of us
will try to confuse somebody and then
the other one will come in and try to
clear it up we'll give them
contradictory notes to see who they like
better yeah
much does a russo brothers
i don't think we can answer a little
embarrassing to answer that question
you're on the pricey side
i think we're at that point where
there's only so much money you can spend
and anything other like beyond that is
irresponsible no matter how much money
you have
you eventually run out one two three
many russo brothers are there
harpo
crowd show we like to point out the name
russo is similar to the name jones in
italian in a sense there's there's a lot
of them
what does the brothers agbo mean
agbo is an interesting story that
predates our time in the film business
aunt and i were working on a comedy show
at a school we were both attending we
thought a great way to attract attention
for this midnight comedy show we were
doing on campus was to have a very
grumpy local resident write a really
shitty review but everything he hated
about the show was everything we loved
about this show so we opened a phone
book and basically just scanned through
it until we found the name ghosie agbo
and cozy agbo became that angry local
resident who trashed our show what i
like about our the name of our company
the most agbo is it makes me feel like
i'm at the eye doctor and i have to read
the chart what is the russo brothers
style
smooth yeah cool under pressure
bond-esque a common thread in our style
is that we like to not have a common
thread something soderberg taught us
very early on when he was mentoring us
was
don't let the world pigeonhole you don't
let them put you in a box we zig and zag
as much as we possibly can and it's more
compelling to us to
uh leave a trail of confusion
what are the russo brothers influences
when we first started making movies
together if you forced us to say our
favorite filmmaker truffaut might have
come out of our mind i think so he's the
best at balancing humor and tragedy what
marvel movies have the russo brothers
directed i mean i think the easier
answer is you just google that so go
google it okay are the russo brothers i
mean that's like very philosophical are
the rooster brothers
that's a shitty question
we're not gonna answer that question
are the russo brothers
good directors i mean
it's another shape
and that really is a subjective uh
question yeah so i think you have to
answer that for yourselves or go to
twitter and let someone else tell you
are the rooster brothers
uh tours no we're not actually we don't
like the uh
the notion of auteur filmmaking because
there are a thousand people that work on
a movie you sit at the film and you
watch the credits roll we uh reject the
auteur theory
how do you like that uh are the russo
brothers releasing a six-hour end game i
think the longest we ever had it was
like three hours and 40 minutes if we
did a super cut of infinity war in the
end game we there could be probably
between the two there could be a six
hour cut yeah i think those 40 minutes
deserve to
be on the
editing floor yeah that's why they went
there in the first place you got the
director's cut yeah that's it there's
nothing else sorry yeah
why the russo brothers why were the
rooster brothers hired i would put the
question were we in fact hired do we
even exist i don't know are we sitting
here right now i'll tell you this a few
times that i've been hired
it's because i really know how to bus
tables why do the russo brothers direct
together
because it's better than directing a
part we learned how to make movies
together and i think that
that we just began a process with one
another
that just
continued to grow uh why did the russo
brothers kill loki he deserved to die
that's all we're saying to them
why did the rooster brothers kill iron
man ah jeez
i see where this is going now
he deserved to die
why did the rooster brothers
hate the hulk oh we nerfed the hulk we
nerfed them and we just didn't know what
to do with them we were like what this
big powerful character what do we do
with this big powerful character can you
find out who wrote this question i'd
like to talk to them
no
uh to say to people who think we nerfed
the hulk he deserved it lots of
controversial yeah marvel
fans responding this one is just russo
brothers
very philosophical as well russo
brothers can the rooster brothers speak
italian
poco we grew up in a very large italian
family very colorful italian family in
cleveland ohio and i think our love for
storytelling started a very young age
where we'd all sit around the dinner
tables on sundays as our extended family
would be 20 30 people at a dinner have
multiple tables set up our
great-grandmother would cook pasta and
we told each other stories about what
happened that week and make each other
laugh you'd uh
our notion of this
you know communal storytelling comes
from
our dinners every sunday and you know
our love for telling stories probably
one of the most significant influences
on
us as artists was um growing up in the
family that we grew up in yeah i think
so i also think that
you know our grandparents immigrated our
great-grandparents immigrated when you
have a family with an immigrant history
there's a journey
uh
inherent in the family story that you
came from somewhere and you're going to
somewhere and there's sort of like those
big questions about identity
and purpose that sort of spoke to our
larger interest in storytelling uh russo
brothers new movie the gray man starring
ryan gosling and chris evans and anna de
armas it's an action thriller it's a
derives from our love of action
thrillers as kids and film fans growing
up we like complex thematics we think
there's some really interesting modern
thematics in the movie uh it's one of
those movies where we hope uh you know
if you're
uh eating your uh popcorn in the theater
that you forget to eat it for most of
the movie or if you're at home watching
it that you put down your cell phone
what distinguishes this movie most from
the action that we've done before is
that it's more grounded in the real
world it's not a sci-fi world it's not a
fantasy world it's the world we all
live in while there's many dimensions of
the story that are larger than life it
still stays tethered to what human
beings are capable of and limited by did
the russo brothers
go to film film school
that's an interesting question yes and
no because we made a movie we made it
for our first movie an independent film
before we went to film school then we
went to film school to use their
equipment to finish the movie then we
took that film to while we were still in
film school to slam dance got to sever
by soderberg steven soderbergh dropped
out of film school so we really never
finished film school yeah we did it a
bit backwards but i will say this i
think we both really appreciated our
time there we did so who did the russo
brothers say is the strongest
avengers wanda at one point captain
marvel another point thor certainly
never said it's the hulk certainly not
the hulk he'd be low on the list like
right underneath gru remember grew the
wanderer he's like just below guru the
wander all right last question we
skipped one so we're gonna go back but
we know it's the best question
so we saved it for last did the russo
brothers make stranger things
yes this is my favorite last question we
made stranger things we did not make
stranger things all credit on that goes
to the duffer brothers who are uh
incredibly talented who are also
twins we are not twins right we're not
twins wait the duffers are twins right
yeah they're twins yeah i was kidding i
think my favorite question was are the
russo brothers google's a powerful tool
it's interesting to know
what uh what people think of you and
apparently our legacy
uh lies somewhere between the duffer
brothers and nerfing the hulk